hey guys it's max max tech today we are
comparing the brand new iPhone 11 Pro
max to the Samsung Galaxy Note 10 to the
hand we're gonna compare the screens the
speaker's the CPU performance the
graphics and find out which one of these
is the better device let's start out
with the actual design of these phones
and looking at the top here the iPhone
definitely looks aged it's a design
that's a couple years old whereas the
note 10 plus has these ultra thin bezels
it has this little centered cutout the
glass is curved to the edges and basing
it just from the top the note tent is
definitely the clear winner now if we go
over to the side Samsung made a nice
design change this year and the frame is
ultra thin all the buttons are on one
side which does take some time to get
used to but it really makes it feel and
look premium and the back glass is
curved all the way up way more than
before and iPhone is really rounded and
curved all around but it is the same
design and then if we flip to the back
completely here looking at it they both
look fantastic now Samsung kind of
copied apple's design as far as the
camera bump it is kind of slimmer
doesn't stick out as much and I thought
it was a nice look and I liked it much
better than the renders for the iPhone
11s camera the little square module but
with that said once they showed off the
final design and it being a flat piece
of glass all one piece that is etched
out I do like the look of the iPhone
better it looks so much better than what
we thought it was gonna be I wasn't a
fan back then now I am and I think the
iPhone looks better from the back now if
we look at the top and the bottom I
really like the flat design it really
stands out compared to the iPhones and
then of course on the bottom we have USB
type-c for the note 10 plus compared to
lightning I wish the iPhone was USB
type-c that is definitely I think the
better way to go so that is better on
the note 10 now along with the exterior
design and the hardware comes
waterproofing and this is one area where
the iPhone definitely has a heads up it
could actually spend half an hour
underwater up to 13 feet deep compared
to the Samsung Note 10 which can only do
half of that now inside of these cases
we have two large batteries the iPhone
finally has
larger battery almost at 4,000 milliamp
hours but the no 10 plus beats it with
4300 milliamp hours now the battery is
not the only thing that matters software
optimization and hardware also make a
huge difference and with a new a 13
Bionic processor Apple made some really
big improvements now when it comes time
to charge we also have some differences
thankfully Apple now finally gives us a
fast charger in the box it's an 18 watt
charger and whereas the Samsung gives us
the charger that's 25 watts both are USB
type-c now we also have some differences
when it comes time to getting into your
device as far as security the iPhone
uses face ID the newest version and
which it allows it to be a little bit
faster and better angles so that is very
very easy to get in it is just so simple
you almost don't even notice that it is
there now Samsung took a different
approach and they're using an ultrasonic
underneath the display fingerprint
scanner it has gotten better over time
but it still is not as convenient and
with their tablets they actually use an
optical sensor which is a little bit
faster but they say this one might be a
bit more secure either way I think as
far as convenience a security face ID
does have the upper hand now a lot of
people have said that the iPhone is now
using the same display tech as the note
10 but I don't think so looking at these
displays I manually turned up the
brightness all the way to compare the
brightness and the iPhone is quite a bit
brighter surprisingly I went through all
the settings made sure that nothing is
turned on that would limit it and it's
actually set to +10 on the note 10 and
it's still quite a bit dimmer now that's
even with true tone turned on with the
iPhone which will adjust the white
balance to match your environment and
that typically does lower the brightness
a bit the off-axis brightness so if
you're looking from the side the iPhone
stays brighter and the note has more
brightness shift and along with that it
also is more reflective now we do have
the screen protector on that comes from
the factory and that could be affecting
it but I would guess that most people
are going to keep that screen protector
on let's finish off with watching a
YouTube video this is a 4k HDR video to
push these to the max the note 10 plus
and right away right off the bat because
of Android can play back at 1440
P resolution which definitely makes it
nice and sharp notice Li higher quality
the other two are supposed to have HDR
but one thing that I found right now is
that the new iPhone 11 pro max has not
been updated with HDR support in the
YouTube map which makes this a more
difficult comparison whereas my older
iPhone 10s max can playback HDR of
course both of these only in 1080p now
I'm gonna look at the differences and I
will kind of point them out to you a bit
but I do have to mention that when
you're watching this back we're
recording and not in HDR you guys are
probably watching not an HDR so just
visually you won't be able to see the
same differences that I can just as I
expected the note 10 plus definitely has
a lot more detail when you're watching
something back which is definitely a
strong suit and with the HDR right here
we have better saturated colors better
contrast compared to the no HDR on the
11pro and the highlights are pulled back
a bit
so overall the experience is better on
the note 10 of course we probably will
get HDR on the iPhone for the future now
what about the audio experience when
you're watching a video or listening to
music let's compare the speakers
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys wow that was very
interesting first off props to Apple for
stepping it up once again and starting
to match up what Samsung is doing with
their s10 and with their no 10 phones
they were closer than I would expect but
there were some noticeable differences
first off the iPhone definitely has much
sharper clearer high notes they've
really really stood out
they definitely change that from the
previous model whereas the note 10 it
doesn't have that but the maids are much
more distinct I guess they're louder you
notice them more but the highs are a
little bit more subdued and along with
that the note 10 has more deeper notes
for the bass now Apple did also talk
about their Dolby Atmos tuning which we
did have turned on with a note and along
with that there kind of surround sound
so let's test that out so I'm playing
this surround sound test of course our
mic is mono so you won't be able to hear
the difference but take my word for it
so first off I can definitely hear the
surround sound effect the whizzing by
now the iPhone a became more balanced
with this generation compared to the
note which became less balanced they
they gave more high frequencies to the
bottom speaker and they made that very
balanced as far as loudness I think that
matters the surround sound I don't feel
like a louder side from the bottom
speaker it's more even when they're
zooming by right there you notice the
surround sound effect much more yeah
it's almost like it's virtual surround
sound but it feels like they're just
coming from the right side or the left
side the iPhone 11 Pro Max is definitely
a step ahead now it's time for
performance we're gonna run a couple of
different benchmarks three actually so
let's start out with Geekbench for the
classic we're gonna run the CPU tests
over here and this is a great time while
it's running while we're waiting to talk
about the specs or at least the chips
now the iPhone is definitely gonna be a
clear winner with the new a 13 Bionic
processor but there are some other
differences that matter and that is RAM
to start off with we have still only
four gigs of RAM with the iPhone 11 Pro
max that's one of my big disappointments
I wish I had at least
whereas we have 12 gigs with the no 10
plus the results are in for Geekbench 4
and we have about 30% higher multi-core
score with the iPhone and almost 60%
higher single core score in a Geekbench
5 we actually see a bigger difference
the multi-court just the difference is
slightly larger but in single core
instead of almost 60% we are now over
85% higher score with iPhone 11 Pro max
now I do have to say that no 10 plus is
still very capable it's a great device
for the time being of course we haven't
looked at graphics yet we'll take a look
that in just a second the results are in
and of course the iPhone is quite a ways
ahead both in a CPU and especially in
the graphics and what my eyes were
seeing are now validated there's a lot
more graphics power in the iPhone now
does that matter right now in the real
world I think we're gonna have to do a
gaming comparison to test that out so if
you guys want to see a real world gaming
comparison with multiple games that are
gonna push these to the limits make sure
you guys are subscribed with those
notifications enabled now another
interesting thing is the memory the RAM
score is actually higher with the iPhone
even though has less RAM but the actual
speed of the RAM is better but the ROM
score which is the speed of the storage
and the performance of that is quite a
bit higher more than double with the
note 10 because it does use the new
storage chips whereas the iPhone looks
like it's still stuck with the older
generation so what about the software
well I still have ante to open and there
is a UX core and it's actually identical
77,000 on both of these meaning they're
both very smooth very fluid they have a
nice experience now of course we do have
a difference in the actual software at
iOS versus Android they both have their
pluses and minuses a lot of people love
iPhones because they just focus on the
tasks they need to do the software gets
out of the way they don't want to
customize it you wanna have it be a good
experiences apps are optimized all that
good stuff but on the Android side you
have a lot more customization it's more
powerful you have a lot more options and
that is definitely a plus now one area
where the iPhone definite leads in
software is updates it's so easy to
upgrade to the next version of iOS it
comes out instantly because Apple
controls both the hardware in the
software where
with Samsung compared to other Android
phones it takes much longer to get
updates to newer versions and they not
support them for as long as iPhones do
you can even have like an iPhone 5s
right now and still have the latest
version of iOS whereas Samsung after a
few years you kind of get left behind
now before we get into the cameras
there's one thing I absolutely have to
mention and that is this little guy
right here we have not talked about it
it is the S Pen and if you're somebody
that wants to write notes you want to
draw you want to have a more accurate
pointer and a device to use that of
course you can only get on the note 10
and that is a major upside of it
personally for myself and a lot of other
people we rarely use the s-pen and for
me it really doesn't matter so this
isn't a significant difference now
another thing that some people may
really like is decks so you can actually
connect it to your PC you can text you
can have photos come over that way so
that's a big plus of course if you have
a Mac you have airdrop and all of
continuity all of that stuff but you can
also take this phone and plug it into an
external display hook up a Bluetooth
keyboard and mouse and be able to use
the phone in that way as basically kind
of like a desktop replacement if you
want to don't want to have a separate
computer not a lot of people use that
but I have to mention it
and now let's talk about the camera so
the iPhone has finally caught up we have
three camera lenses on the back we have
a telephoto standard or wide depending
how they want to call it and an
ultra-wide same thing with a note 10 and
on the front we also have some high
quality front-facing cameras the note 10
is a 10 megapixel now compared to 12
megapixel which is an upgrade from 7
with 11 pro max you guys let me know
which one looks better they both have a
wider mode one difference is if you want
to do a portrait selfie you don't have
access to that wider mode with the
iPhone and you do with the Samsung now
on the back the ultra whites also have a
difference with the iPhone we have a 13
millimeter equivalent to full-frame and
the note tens is actually wider is also
a 16 megapixel ultra light compared to
12 megapixel Apple put a huge focus on
the fact that all of these lenses are
matched up 13:26 52 and with that we can
actually zoom in and have it be a
very nice smooth transition they're
matching these from the factory so that
the colors and exposure match up really
well
another thing Apple was really proud of
is their new night mode so they finally
caught up and they have that but there
is a couple differences it goes and
automatically you can't just enable it
by default like you can with the notes
and you can only use the night mode on
the wide lens and the telephoto you
can't do it on the front-facing or the
ultra wide whereas with the note 10 plus
you can use it for all of the cameras
let me know down in the comments section
which one of these you think did better
from this small sample of images but of
course we're gonna have to do a lot more
testing and we're gonna make a detailed
video covering a lot of different
scenarios and a lot of different
situations so make sure you guys are
subscribed with notifications enabled so
you guys don't miss out on that great
video now on to the prices both of these
come in at $1,100 but that doesn't tell
the whole story first off you can
actually get the note 10 plus for $1000
or a little bit less if you search
around and you can also find bundle
deals like for example you get the
galaxy buzz included for the same price
which is awesome we'll leave a link down
in the video description now along with
that the note 10 plus comes with 256
gigabytes a faster storage built in and
if you want that with the iPhone 11 pro
max you gotta spend another hundred and
fifty dollars more and we also have a
micro SD card tray so you can add in
your own cheap storage as well so if we
look at the whole overall picture if you
are not tied in to the iPhone in the
ecosystem then I think the note 10 plus
really has a lot of advantages and for a
lower price overall which makes it kind
of the better buy but of course if you
want I owe s if you want to add it into
your collection of iPads Macs Apple
watch stuff like that then it's still a
really good device and Apple made some
really great improvements so if you guys
want to see a couple other videos we
have them right over there if you guys
want to subscribe that's right up top
and a little notifications below and
make sure you guys are subscribed for
that photo comparison thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]